بانها شركه عسكريه خاصه ويراها اخرون اقرب
ما تكون الى مجموعه روسيه عسكريه شبه
رسميه فهي وحده تتمتع وفق صحيفه نيويورك
بالاستقلاليه وتتبع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
يعتقد ان مؤسسها هو ديمتري اوكين ضابط
سابق في القوات الخاصه وحملت اسمه السري
فاغنر لكنها الان مملوكه لرجل الاعمال
ويعرف باسم الطباخ بوتين لادارته شركه
كونكورد المنظمه لحفلات الاستقبال
بالكرملين وتضم مزيجا من مقاتلين يقدمون
خدماتهم مقابل المال بدات العمل لاول مره
مع ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره القرم في عام 2014
ونفذت هجمات في شرق اوكرانيا يقول مسؤولون
بريطانيون ان عدد مقاتل فاجندر ارتفع من
نحو الف الى ما يقرب من 20000 مقاتل في
اوكرانيا اي نحو عشره في المئه من اجمالي
القوات الروسيه على الارض افتتح بريكوجين
اول في مدينه سان بطرسبورغ الروسيه وقال
في بيانه مهمه مركز فاجنر هي توفير بيئه
مريحه لتوليد افكار جديده بغيه تحسين
القدره الدفاعيه لروسيا وتحسين القدره
الدفاعيه لروسيا لا يمكنه اخفاء حقيقه
الاتهامات لفاجنر بارسال مسلحيها الى عده
دول في امريكا اللاتينيه وافريقيا وتنفيذ
ما توصف بالعمليه القذره في مناطق
النزاعات المختلفه ففي سوريا انتشرت فاجنر
لدعم نظام السوري منذ 2016 خصوصا حول حقول
النفط في دير الزور وخطفت الاضواء اكثر
بعد مقتل عدد من افرادها في غاره امريكيه
عام 2018
وتنشط المجموعه في ليبيا منذ 2016 وتدعم
القوات المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر وكشف تقرير سري للامم المتحده وجود
اكثر من 1000 من عناصرها لكن تقارير اخرى
تقدرهم بالالاف
كما تنتشر في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
لحراسه مناجم الذهب والالماس وتشير تقارير
الى وجود لها في مدغشقر وموزمبيق والسودان
وكان اخر انتشار لها في مالي بعد انسحاب
القوات الفرنسيه من هناك